[Musique]
4 ko si tu nous a demandé un autre
cadeau regardez c'est le thé le cadeau
d'angélique regarder ça lui ben moi 100
g league
voilà ça fait 17 ans que j'ai pas pris
une journée pour moi et donc j'aimerais
beaucoup que pour une fois on pense à
moi merci d'où je dis toujours je veux
angélique vous êtes mère au foyer
vous êtes mariée à nicolas et depuis que
vous avez vos enfants vous n'êtes jamais
sorti vous ne vous êtes jamais venus
une journée pour vous pour qui fait
c'est ça ou pas oui c'est ça c'était
vraiment votre souhait le plus cher
votre cadeau de noël voilà pouvoir aller
qui fait un petit peu oui
faire les boutiques aller chez le
coiffeur et donc on a demandé à mokhtar
de garder vos enfants
et oui c'est le cadeau de mokhtar on va
regarder ça c'est parti on a approché
j'arrive devant chez angélique les
enfants ne sont pas encore en ce mois
ressort presque surpris quand j'ai dit
que j'aime bien oui ça va
et vous à toi j'ai envoyé par baba noël
scolaire par baba et m'envoyer john
cette carte illimitée ta journée de
princesse
on va s'occuper de toi de partout allez
pour toi et moi pendant ce temps là je
te garde a trois enfants
ouais du monde sont pas tous comme un
geek huit enfants à les battre
[Applaudissements]
sai baba noël il m'a envoyé moi je
t'appelle natori g10 mari j'ai 16 ans
qui m'anime c'est un yoann g 11 ans elle
ou il est d'accord que l'on sait j'ai 14
ans et voilà qu ami avait 15 ou 20 mars
quand on manque d'argent ont dit au
revoir à ma vie et je vais y aller
quinn a dit leur avoir donné mon nom
[Musique]
bon maintenant les enfants nous ça va
être la guerre nazis en fanfare manger
je veux faire à manger les enfants
voulaient manger quoi est fait pour tout
le monde ok on va faire des pâtes des
pâtes on tombe en effet mais leurs
pattes
le temps que les pratiques eu des
enfants à faire la vérité qu'il
collectionnait t on va commencer par
noam shalit et vérité combien gagnent
solana
quand je vois si la patrie sont cuites
autant à si on était allé vous fait
d'eux les 9 actions
est ce que tu peux nous faire un plat de
viande ou toitures
oui ok après oui à l'étape de demain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà ça s'envoie action vérité vous
avez été vifs
ou pas
[Musique]
mais pas à la tunisie merci qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
tu veux je te raconte une petite
histoire il était une fois dans une
banlieue du 9 3 un agent de ce qui vous
était super beau gosse super musclé avec
un style d'un malade
bon maintenant je veux tu as profité un
petit rap mais ils sont classés
détiendront 10 partout je le raconte au
maire contre classée oin oin
[Musique]
la tuque au débat tiens c'est pas grave
à la palma cas cela suppose d'abord à
vous de jouer à ça bon allez je voulais
jouer sa partie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 17 ans je suis maman je devais sortie
pour faire 1
hu a dit vino
je vais
mais que tu
bon maintenant on va faire un gâteau au
chocolat t'as pas senti matin sont
importantes aussi bien maintenant vous
allez bien comme on casse les voilà on
prend neuf d'un cinéma et après on tarde
pas là entre espoir et à prendre un peu
de farine
[Musique]
mais
maintenant tout ça va doucher
[Musique]
un jour
c'est génial oui très bien
ouais bon jour non je dis oui merci
c'est qu'on aurait dû se terminer et
j'en étais super gentille et super sage
manger ils ont écouté on a joué tous
fait les enfants j'étais super ça joue
beaucoup aidé aussi avoir les enfants de
1 à 4
[Musique]
moi ça me manquait a pas lu ce rapport
rocard
bon ça car mon cas
alors j'ai quelque chose à vous dire
c'est vous parce que en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est angélique aussi a les
larmes aux yeux je ferai des hobbies ou
angélique surtout elle ne savait pas ce
qui s'était passé et elle est
extrêmement maniaque donc là vous étiez
en angoisse sur le magnéto angélique de
foudre oui c'est vraiment tout était
rangé après ben oui moi j'ai rien vu on
n'avait rien vu du tout bas motard est
magnifique avec les équipes de
production et vous avez fait un kif pour
la première fois voilà vous êtes allé
chez le coiffeur il faut le refaire si
vous voulez la prochaine fois on vous
renvoie mokhtar bien oui franchement
vous laisse je sais pas j'étais content
des enfants parce qu'ils sont tous le
grand public à kimberley yas marina
clément siano amiens nat aurillac et van
daele binayak amis et et je vous le dis
bien sûr on les aime fort et on pouvait
pas les laisser partir comme ça puisque
tous les enfants auront des cadeaux ce
soir et repartir avec leurs cadeaux de
noël
il ya des consoles de jeux ya déjà des
smartphones ya de tout pour eux un
cadeau pour tous les enfants
quand j'ai dit c'est baba noël et c'est
moctar noël surtout les offres ça je
vous fais un énorme bisou angélique sans
manger ni et elle est toute émue mercier
angélique l'arrivée
merci angélique est avec look est
formidable versions du tu veux partir
avec le micro cadeau c'est roger des
quêtes avec l'ouverture jeudi
[Applaudissements]